I would say sort of no we we have
actually grown a lot in the past you
know ten 15 years you know what what
what you know a lot of investors or so
that a lot of partners actually ask you
what what what's the driving force right
in your secret sauce number one is
actually luck right yeah we we actually
sort of knew in the right place you know
at the right time but also sort of you
know I would say you know there's a
culture at $0.10 which actually tries to
create value for the users
you know we our missions actually
enhance people's quality of life
through internet services I think you
know that that's an important thing that
drives you know the 20,000 people at
$0.10 to think about sort of what they
can contribute to the users we have a
team which is very young you know 28
years old in on average you know we are
very aggressive in terms of hiring fresh
breath so you know for all the students
here right now if you would consider it
I would do a pitch you know consider a
10 cent and and also I think we also
have a pretty diverse senior management
team right you know so out of our 16
members of the management committee
about half of them actually sort of know
lived aboard right now of course we have
a lot of new local Chinese exposure but
about half of the senior management they
actually did the board and then sort of
two of them are actually non Chinese one
of them is actually an American the
other one is actually a Brit so we we
have a pretty diverse group of people
what we have lacking is actually a woman
senior executive so you know any woman
student who who wants to take back to
that we we have a wide invitation to
that